public cette semaine nous déshabillons
en tout bien tout honneur quelques stars
de la connectique lorsqu'elle se met à
nu
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre cet après-midi sur notre
antenne l'examen du projet de loi
relatif à l'évolution institutionnelle
de mayotte et de la nouvelle calédonie
ce projet de loi concrétise la
transformation de mayotte en 101e
département français
rappelons que lors du référendum de mars
2009 les maoris ont approuvé à près de
95%
la départementalisation de leur île en
ce qui concerne la nouvelle calédonie ce
projet de loi doit permettre la mise en
oeuvre des accords de nouméa qui prévoit
le transfert des compétences de l'état
vers la nouvelle calédonie et qui
déboucheront à terme vers un scrutin
d'autodétermination
voilà pour les enjeux de cet après midi
bonne séance à tous sur public sénat la
séance s'est reprise
j'ai le plaisir de vous informer que
monsieur gérard longuet a été pré élu
président de l'ue gros du groupe de
l'union pour un mouvement populaire
je voulais le féliciter au nom du sénat
et de nous informer que monsieur nicolas
abou a été élu président du groupe de
l'union centriste et de le féliciter au
nom du sénat l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi organique
relatif à l'évolution institutionnelle
de la nouvelle calédonie et de mayotte
et du projet de loi relatif à
l'évolution institutionnelle la nouvelle
calédonie et portant ratification
d'ordonnancés discussion générale la
parole et à madame marie-luce penchard
secrétaire d'état chargée de l'outre-mer
je voulais un homme le ministre puisque
c'est votre première prise de parole
dans cet hémicycle vous souhaitez sur le
texte mais aussi pour la fonction qui
vous a et la mission qui vous ont été
confiées par le président de la
république
nos meilleurs voeux de réussite
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs
nous allons examiner un texte qui porte
effectivement sur l'évolution
institutionnelle de la nouvelle
calédonie et de mayotte lé texte examiné
par le sénat
selon la procédure accélérée marque une
étape importante pour la nouvelle
calédonie et mayotte
je sais que certains d'entre vous
s'interrogent sur l'intitulé d'un texte
qui porte à la fois sur l'évolution
institutionnelle de mayotte et sereine
nouvelle calédonie je voudrais vous
rassurer
n'y voyez aucun message particulier du
gouvernement c'est la contrainte du
calendrier parlementaire qui a conduit à
cette présentation commune
bien évidemment chaque collectivité fait
son propre cheminement comme le prévoit
la constitution
ce sont deux trajectoires différentes
que nous respectons et que nous
accompagnons donc je voulais le dire au
préalable
ce texte de loi est une étape importante
pour mayotte car le projet de loi
organique consac ainsi que le prévoit
notre constitution
le changement de statut décidé par nos
compatriotes
le 29 mars dernier à 95% la collectivité
unique prendra la place les institutions
existantes en 2011 bien évidemment les
dispositions de la loi organique
concernant mayotte n'est qu'une étape il
faudra d'autres textes ultérieurs qui
vont être soumis au parlement pour
organiser la transition entre le régime
actuel et la collectivité unique
à ce sujet je voudrais signaler que le
gouvernement souscrit à la rédaction
nouvelle de cet article adopté par la
commission des lois qui transcrit
clairement le fait qu'à compter de mars
2011 une nouvelle collectivité sera en
vigueur ce projet de loi et surtout une
étape importante pour la nouvelle
calédonie les textes qui vous sont
soumis sont dans la continuité de
l'accord de nouméa
1998 et dans l'esprit de cet accord car
le consensus a toujours été le fil
directeur de nos travaux tous les
projets de loi avant d'être soumis aux
parlements sont été nourri des travaux
réalisés depuis 2006 en nouvelle
calédonie pour modifier le statut de
cette collectivité
il faut savoir que le comité des
signataires du 2 février 2006 a confié à
un groupe de travail réunissant
l'ensemble des partenaires locaux le
soin de faire des propositions sur une
révision du statut les propositions et
des remises par ce groupe de travail est
la grande majorité de celles ayant fait
l'objet de consensus local sont reprises
dans les actuels projets de loi alors
vous le voyez une partie importante du
projet porte sur la modernisation du
statut pourquoi car le statut actuel de
la nouvelle calédonie issus des loi
organique et ordinaire du 19 mars 1999
est en effet antérieurs à ceux de la
plupart des collectivités d'outre-mer à
l'exception de wallis et futuna
tous ont été élaborés aux mises à jour
en 2007 alors que pour la nouvelle
calédonie ce statut et n'a pratiquement
pas été révisés et il paraissait
nécessaire d'harmoniser les règles qui
ont vocation à être commune à l'ensemble
des collectivités alors le texte propose
des modifications qui porte notamment
sur l'harmonisation des règles relatives
à la consultation la nouvelle calédonie
sur les projets de loi et les
ordonnances sur la création d'un
véritable statut de l'élu
je pense que tous les élus s'en
féliciteront garantissant une protection
efficace notamment au plan juridique
ce texte prévoit l'institution procédure
d'expédition des affaires courantes et
de modernisation des recours devant la
juridiction administrative
la modification de la loi organique de
1999 vise en fait à clarifier la
répartition des compétences
elle permet par exemple l'extension je
dirai au sénat coutumier
du régime des inéligibilités et des
incompatibilités elle permet par exemple
la possibilité pour le congrès des
dictées par la loi du pays un véritable
statut de la fonction publique néo
calédonienne mais le projet de loi que
vous examinez 6 aussi des conditions
d'intervention économique plus souple
qui s'accompagne et jean fisse illicites
je dirais l'ensemble des signataires des
accords qui ont beaucoup participé à ce
travail pour que ces conditions
d'intervention économique plus souple
s'accompagne d'une transparence
renforcée alors ces conditions
économiques
elles seront maintenant possible grâce à
la possibilité qui va être donnée à la
nouvelle calédonie de créer des
groupements d'intérêt public locaux
entre la nouvelle calédonie les
provinces et les personnes publiques ou
privées en vue de faciliter la
coopération entre les institutions
locales
cette modification je dirais de la loi
organique permettra la participation des
établissements publics des provinces au
capital de société privée gérant un
service public ou d'intérêt général
elle permettra la possibilité pour les
provinces d'accorder des subventions aux
entreprises
enfin sera donné la possibilité de
déléguer un service public dans le
respect des principes de la loi sapin
mais parallèlement et dans le souci
d'une plus grande transparence de la vie
économique et c'est important de le dire
ce texte permet d'organiser une
meilleure information du progrès sur les
interventions locales en matière
économique
il permettra l'extension du contrôle de
légalité du haut-commissaire aux actes
des établissements publics
enfin il procède à une réelle
modernisation du contrôle budgétaire des
interdits cement publics locaux alors
s'agissant du volet des transferts de
compétences qui prend une part
importante de ce projet de loi
sachez que le gouvernement a loyalement
transcrit les conclusions du comité
les signataires de l'accord de nouméa 18
décent et préalablement il a fallu un
long travail de préparation et de
réflexion entre les signataires de cet
accord pour que ces transferts de
compétences prévus par l'accord soit
effectivement
conduit dans les mêmes conditions qui
était prévu le comité des signataires du
8 décembre a validé l'ensemble des
propositions relatives à la révision de
loi organique et c'est cet esprit
d'équilibré général du consensus validé
dans les termes très précis le 8
décembre dernier qui est aujourd'hui
repris dans les projets de textes dont
le parlement est saisi
alors la réussite du transfert des
compétences suppose par ailleurs une
adaptation des structures
administratives et les signataires ont
souhaité que de réelles garanties soient
apportées pour le maintien de la qualité
du service rendu à nos compatriotes
calédonien c'est pourquoi des solutions
concrètes et innovantes associant l'état
et les institutions locales
on peut être ainsi proposés dans le
texte c'est notamment la création de
services mixte permettant ainsi la
coexistence d'attribution de l'état et
de la nouvelle calédonie au sein de
mêmes services
ce sont des dispositions spécifiques
concernant les personnels de l'éducation
nationale qui sont également proposés de
manière à assurer une transition la
mieux adaptée et les prévu dans un
premier temps à ce titre une mise à
disposition globale des services
par ailleurs le projet veille à la
compensation financière intégrale des
compétences transférées le mode de
cohorte de compensation des transferts
sera même plus favorable qu'en métropole
puisque la dotation de compensation sera
indexée sur la dotation globale de
fonctionnement alors qu'en métropole la
dotation globale est des intérêts xi en
matière de sécurité civile
le projet prévoit que la nouvelle
calédonie et les provinces apporteront
le concours à l'établissement public
d'incendié de secours
cette mutualisation des moyens ira de
pair avec le concours de l'état dans le
cadre du fonds d'aidé à l'investissement
qu'un projet d'ordonnancé en cours
d'examen devant le conseil d'état
prévoit d'étendre à la nouvelle
calédonie enfin le projet prévoit un
accompagnement technique aux transferts
de compétences dans le cadre de
conventions qui pourront être conclues
par la nouvelle calédonie
avec les administrations centrales et
les autorités administratives
indépendantes
cet accompagnement technique permettra
d'éviter toute rupture dans la mise en
oeuvre des compétences et garantira
ainsi une continuité administrative sans
préjudicier au libre exercice par les
institutions de leurs compétences
nouvelles
il s'agit là voyez-vous d'aider le
gouvernement calédonien a élaboré sa
propre réglementation dans les complexes
dans des domaines complexes comme le
droit des affaires ou de la concurrence
le congrès de la nouvelle calédonie a
proposé une série d'amendements destinés
à améliorer du point de vue de la
nouvelle calédonie l' équilibre
budgétaire des transferts je dois
rappeler clairement que le projet de loi
présenté par le gouvernement est
conforme aux engagements inscrits en
décembre dernier lors du comité des
signataires
non seulement la nouvelle calédonie
n'est pas en retrait par rapport au
droit comme en matière de transferts
mais encore elle bénéficie d'une
dotation indexé sur la dgf ce qui n'est
plus le cas depuis cette année pour les
dotation d'équipement à ce titre la
commission des lois a figé la période de
référence pour la dotation de
compensation des investissements de
manière à inclure la construction du
lycée du grand nouméa le gouvernement
adhère à cette proposition
en revanche la formulation retenue pour
la participation de l'état au
financement des opérations engagées
n'est pas conforme aux conclusions du
comité des signataires et risque d'avoir
des effets sur l'échéancier du transfert
de la compétence
le gouvernement a déposé un amendement
qui dit ce risque
s'agissant des compétences droit civil
réglemente règles concernant l'état
civil droit commercial et sécurité
civile le comité signataires avaient
décidé qu'elle serait transférée selon
les modalités prévues à l'article 27 de
la loi organique
ce changement a soulevé des objections
lors de l'examen du texte par le conseil
d'état sa conformité à la constitution
ayant été débattus votre rapporteur
propose une rédaction qui revient à
l'équilibré actuel de la loi organique
tout en tenant compte
des difficultés propres aux deux blocs
de compétences pour lesquels les
signataires de l'accord en jugé
nécessaires des préalables
cette position sur laquelle nous avons
consulté nos partenaires nous semble
conforme au consensus qui se dégage
actuellement et est de nature à garantir
que les transferts interviendront
effectivement dans le délai prescrit par
l'accord de nouméa
l'assouplissement toutefois doit être
strictement circonscrits aux seules
compétences qui devait être introduite à
l'article 27
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs le
gouvernement vous soumets deux textes
qui sont en grande partie le produit du
consensus et traduisent un équilibre
politique entre les signataires de
l'accord dont l'état est à la fois le
garant est l'un des acteurs pour le
gouvernement
le consensus de tous les partenaires
c'est manifester le 8 décembre le
congrès a donné un avis favorable à
l'unanimité sur les projets de textes
sous réserve de plusieurs modifications
si le gouvernement ne méconnaît pas le
poids politique de l'accord trouvé il a
également sa vision et ses
responsabilités dans le processus
c'est pourquoi certaines évolutions nous
paraissent peu opportune plus
fondamentalement ces textes marque la
volonté très claire du gouvernement
signataires de l'accord de nouméa
d'assurer que les transferts de
compétences qui doivent impérativement
intervenir avant l'échéance fixée dans
l'accord c'est à dire 2014 soit effectif
dans les conditions les plus
opérationnels et dans le souci de
maintenir la qualité des services rendus
les transferts sont la clé de réussite
de l'accord de nouméa et le gouvernement
vous confirme pas ma voix qu'il entend
bien que ce processus soit poursuivi
merci
merci madame la ministre
la parole est maintenant monsieur
christian cointat rapporteur au nom de
la commission des lois avait la parole
monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
l'essentiel du débat qui s'ouvre devant
nous portent sur deux points
particulièrement important à savoir le
transfert de compétences sur la nouvelle
calédonie et la départementalisation de
mayotte
ces deux sujets n'ont aucun lien entre
eux ils ne se trouvent dans le même
véhicule législatif que pour deux de
pures raisons de convenance pratique
madame la ministre nous l'a rappelé tout
à l'heure nous pouvons certes comprendre
ce souci de rationalisation mais
permettez moi quand même à l'âme la
ministre de le regretter la politique
surtout quand elle est sensible et
parfois plus simple quand elle n'est pas
trop simplifié
c'était le cas ici car plusieurs des
élus et dirigeants locaux des deux
territoires concernés m'ont fait part à
juste titre lors de leurs auditions de
leur regret et interrogations face à un
amalgame pour le moins curieux mais nous
savons désormais puisque vous nous
l'avez affirmé madame la ministre
qu'ils peuvent être rassurés car aucune
malice ne se cachent d'ailleurs ce
rapprochement de simple circonstance
quand vous le savez mes chers collègues
le statut de la nouvelle calédonie est
le fruit des accords de matignon puis de
nouméa concrétisée par la loi organique
du 19 mars 1999 est consacrée par un
titre spécial de notre constitution les
règles et principes édictés sont ainsi
gravé dans le marbre de la république
on peut d'ailleurs s'en féliciter car ce
dispositif institutionnel
quelles que puissent être les critiques
qu'il a suscitées accompagné par une
volonté et un engagement des
responsables calédoniens toutes
sensibilités confondues majorité comme
opposition de travailler ensemble a
permis à ce territoire de retrouver
depuis plus de 20 ans la paix la
prospérité et un important développement
économique qui le placent dans le
peloton de tête tout à fait en tête de
la zone océanie pacifique
alors mes chers collègues pourquoi une
nouvelle loi organique
la nouvelle calédonie tout simplement
parce que l'expérience commande quelques
adaptations et autres réglages dont la
nécessité s'impose naturellement
les signataires de l'accord de nouméa
ans ont d'ailleurs convenu
j'évoquerai brièvement la teneur des
projets de loi organique et ordinaire
déposé par le gouvernement puisque
madame la ministre en a brossé les
grandes lignes et développer les points
seuil
en fait pour ce qui concerne la nouvelle
calédonie l'objectif principal est de
faciliter la mise en oeuvre des
transferts de compétences qui reste à
accomplir avant 2014 autrement dit avant
la fin du mandat du congrès qui vient
d'être élu et de définir les moyens
techniques humains et financiers que
l'état pourra mettre à la disposition de
la nouvelle calédonie pour accompagner
ces transferts
d'autres dispositions a sur un
renforcement du rôle des élus et
davantage de transparence financière
enfin plusieurs articles apporte
précision et clarification le projet de
loi organique porte également sur la
départementalisation de mayotte
quant au projet de loi ordinaire il
traite essentiellement d'ajustements
techniques et propose la ratification
d'une série d'ordonnancés l'accord de
nouméa fellak l'objet d'un suivi
régulier lors de réunions rassemblant
les acteurs calédonien les représentants
de l'état
la plupart des propositions retenues par
le projet de loi organique reprennent
les conclusions de ces comités du suivi
et bien entendu le congrès de nouvelle
calédonie a été consulté par le
gouvernement de son côté votre
commission des lois a mandaté votre rang
porter afin d'entendre les différents
acteurs de la vie politique calédonienne
soit directement à l'occasion de leur
passage à paris soit par le biais de
vacation téléphonique ainsi presque tous
les responsables ont été auditionnés
mais tous en tout cas avaient été
invités à s'exprimer
les aménagements proposés à la loi
organique de 1999 portant statut la
nouvelle calédonie concerne les
calédoniens temps pour leur avenir que
pour la maîtrise de leur destin quel que
soit celui pour lequel
ils opteront le moment venu il a donc
paru essentiel à votre commission et
autres rapporteurs de suivre au plus
près chaque fois que possible
l'avis des élus du territoire en effet
ce n'est pas à paris que l'on connaît le
mieux la réalité du quotidien calédonie
ce n'est pas à paris que l'on vivra la
disposition votée alors dans le rapport
que nous vous présentons dans le texte
que nous vous soumettons mes chers
collègues nous avons tout simplement
placé au centre de notre approche celles
et ceux majorité comme opposition qui
auront sur place la charge d'appliquer
et de gérer les conséquences des lois
que nous sommes en train d'adopter la
loi organique de 1999 prévoit dans son
article 21 grand troyes toute une série
de compétences sont transférées au cours
des mandats commence en 2004 et 2009 en
précisant dans son article 26 que les
transferts avec l'échéancier
correspondant nécessite une loi du pays
adoptée à la majorité des trois
cinquièmes des membres du congrès et je
cite au plus tard le dernier jour du
sixième mois suivant le début de chaque
mandat
l'énumération de ces compétences suffit
à démontrer leur importance et leur
complexité police et sécurité en matière
de circulation aérienne intérieure de
circulation maritime dans les eaux
territoriales enseignements du second
degré public et privé notamment
enseignement primaire privée droit civil
est à civile droits commerciaux dont un
commercial sécurité civile comme ses
compétences n'ont pas été transférées ni
commencé à transférer en 2004 d'après
cet article 26 il ne nous reste plus qu
à peine six mois même pas cinq mois pour
s'exécuter
or le comité des signataires de l'accord
de nouméa est convenu à juste titre que
ce délai était trop court pour les
quatre compétences suivantes droit civil
est à civil droit commercial sécurité
civile compte tenu notamment de la
nécessité de délimiter clairement le
périmètre de chacune d'entre elles
et de mettre en place un dispositif
normatif pour l'évolution du droit et
cela n'est pas facile
nous avons essayé au sein de la
commission des lois d'examiner s'il
était possible de clarifier les choses
en ce domaine en esquissant un périmètre
et dans le temps qui nous était imparti
cela est avéré s'est avéré une tâche
impossible
alors il faut trouver une solution
il avait donc été suggéré comme solution
de faire glisser ces quatre compétences
de l'article 21 qui prévoit une loi du
pays à l'article 27 de la loi organique
99 qui offre pour d'autres domaines
d'ailleurs de compétences un dispositif
plus souple avec une simple résolution
du congrès demandant à l'état de
procéder lui-même au transfert de ses
compétences pour le blé dur organique
autrement dit si le congrès n'arrivait
pas dans les six mois à régler la
question
on pouvait passer la main au
gouvernement oui cette approche est
certes astucieuse je le reconnais bien
volontiers mais votre commission des
lois ne l'a pas retenue car elles
présentent un fort risque
d'inconstitutionnalité pas une certitude
à la lecture attentive des textes mais
une probabilité élevée et nous avons
estimé qu'on ne devait pas prendre ce
risque
en effet toutes les parties seraient mis
dans l'embarras si cet article était
invalidée par le conseil constitutionnel
d'ailleurs le conseil d'état a
semble-t-il jeudi semble-t-il parce que
tout le monde en parle mais personne ne
l'a vu tout au moins au niveau du
parlement
son texte a semble-t-il fait la même
analyse en effet un tel dispositif
ouvrirait la possibilité de retirer ces
quatre compétences à laquelle et l'oni
puisque le parlement par nature
pourraient s'opposer au transfert en ne
votant pas la loi organique
nous sommes en démocratie et un
parlement est libre de voter ce qu'il
souhaite et ne peut recevoir donc dans
ce sens donc votre commission par
sagesse a préféré allonger pour ces
quatre compétences et uniquement pour
elle de six mois à deux ans le délai
fixé à l'article 26 sans le moindre
glissement possible de l'article 20
vers l'article 27 comme ça nous espérons
que le conseil constitutionnel sera
rassuré et nous accordera comme valable
au point de vue de la constitution
cette augmentation du délai puisque nous
ne modifions pas les équilibres des
compétences et des pouvoirs comme j'ai
déjà annoncé tout à l'heure votre
commission s'est donc efforcé de retenir
le maximum de suggestions présentées par
le congrès de calédonie et a ainsi
adopté un grand nombre d'amendements
présentés dans ce sens tant par votre
rapporteur que par notre excellent
collègue simon loueckhote sénateurs de
nouvelle calédonie ainsi que vous pouvez
vous en douter
le chapitre des compensations
financières humaines et techniques est
un élément central est particulièrement
sensible de ces transferts
comme vous le savez également l'article
40 de la constitution ne nous laisse
qu'une marge de manoeuvre réduite à sa
plus simple expression
nous nous sommes donc par essence
limiter aux seules propositions émises
par le congrès qui pouvaient franchir ce
filtre inexorable depuis plusieurs
années différents textes de loi
organique et ordinaire ont adapté le
statut et l'encadrement normatif de
l'outre-mer votre commission des lois
est très attaché à ce que ces
aménagements restent cohérents entre eux
et dénote une volonté politique
parfaitement lisible
d'autant plus que votre commission des
lois la démontrer régulièrement est très
attaché à l'outre-mer ainsi
estime-t-elle que des situations
absolument comparable appelle des restes
des réponses législatives
analog les adaptations du texte du
projet de loi organique ont donc été
introduite dans ce sens notamment par
rapport à la polynésie pour que la
cohérence soit parfaitement visible
votre commission également insisté sur
le renforcement du rôle des élus en
complétant le projet du gouvernement qui
est à saluer dans ce sens elle s'est
aussi penché sur la transparence
financière et budgétaire et le contrôle
qui doit en découler
divers aménagements ont été apportés en
matière d'inéligibilité et
d'incompatibilité électorale enfin votre
commission après un entretien approfondi
avec le cabinet du président du sénat
coutumier a estimé qu'il était
nécessaire de mieux souligner le rôle de
cette institution qui représente un
élément important de l'accord de nouméa
comme souligné l'autorité de son
président en ce qui concerne mayotte
le projet de loi organique ne comporte
qu'un seul article
mettez à l'article puisqu'il transforme
la collectivité de mayotte en
département à partir du renouvellement
de son conseil général en 2011
comme je l'aï dit lors de mon propos
liminaire il est dommage que cet article
était rattaché aux dispositifs relatifs
à la nouvelle calédonie et cela tant
pour les uns calédonien que pour les
autres morts il fallait un projet de loi
organique pour la calédonie un autre
projet de loi organique pour mayotte
puisque tel n'était pas le cas votre
commission à la suite de ces auditions
avec les élus de mayotte a estimé qu'il
n'était pas souhaitable en définitif
d'aboutir à un article le flottant
relatifs à mayotte
quelque part dans l'immensité des lois
organiques de la république mais au
moins deux rattachés cet article pour
qu'ils soient clairement identifiés au
code général des collectivités publiques
tel est le sens de du texte retenu par
la commission à votre commission des
lois enfin pour terminer mon propos par
la loi ordinaire qui est essentiellement
nature technique dans votre commission
des lois propose par ailleurs de
requalifier une partie vers le niveau
organique
je me limiterai apporter un point qui me
paraît important en ce qui concerne les
pouvoirs du parlement
votre commission des lois vous propose
de ne pas ratifier une ordonnance du 4
au 14 mai 2009
je précise tout de suite qu'il ne s'agit
nullement d'une quelconque opposition
avec les choix opérés dans ce texte ou
du moins pour l'essentiel du texte par
le gouvernement mais d'une réaction
forte et je le dis clairement à
l'attitude de notre commission des
finances en effet
après plusieurs auditions avec les
parties prenantes
votre rapporteur avait suggéré à la
commission des lois de ratifier
l'ordonnancé à l'exception de l'un de
ses articles qui supprimait une aide de
l'état
minimes par ailleurs est pratiquement
jamais utilisés dont les bénéficiaires
n'avait été ni consultés ni informés et
protester de cette attitude à juste
titre cela donc pour invité l'état à
prendre contact avec les personnes
intéressées et ensuite procéder aux
ajustements nécessaires qui pouvait très
bien d'ailleurs aboutir au même résultat
j'avais donc déposé un amendement dans
ce sens or la commission des finances a
opposé l'article 40
tenez vous bien mes chers collègues au
motif que l'entrée en vigueur de
l'ordonnancé incriminé avait supprimé
une charge que l'amendement de votre
rapporteur réintroduisez et qui tombait
de fait sous le coup de l'article 40
or je tiens à vous souligner mes chers
collègues que le pouvoir de ratifier ou
non une ordonnance relève
constitutionnellement du parlement ce
serait très grave que par le biais de
l'article 40 on revienne à retirer ce
pouvoir de ratification d'une manière ou
d'une autre au parlement pour que ce
droit ne soit donc ni supprimer ni
altérer votre commission des lois n'a
pas eu d'autre choix que de refuser la
ratification de l'ordonnancé dans sa
totalité
ce qui revient d'ailleurs à réintroduire
la fameuse charge incriminés ça devient
un peu ubuesque si vous me pardonnez
l'expression
il serait donc temps mais je le dis tout
de suite ses propos ne sont pas
prononcés maintenant en tant que
rapporteur
mais en tant que sénateur puisqu'il
n'engage que moi il serait donc temps
que l'on fixe enfin un cadre des normes
claires pour l'application de l'article
40 qui puisse donner toute sa place à
l'intérêt bien compris de la nation
comme au bon sens dans le respect de la
constitution c'est le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues votre
commission des lois vous invite donc à
approuver son rapport complété enrichie
par une série d'amendements que nous
examinerons lors de la discussion des
articles
comme vous le savez dans les sujets
importants et sensibles
c'est par la force des idées la volonté
de partage
l'ouverture aux autres rechercher la
compréhension des autres et à comprendre
ses partenaires c'est par le dialogue et
la conviction que l'on peut progresser
dans l'intérêt de tous c'est ce que nous
cherchons à faire le gouvernement comme
votre commission des lois et je l'espère
le parlement dans l'intérêt bien compris
de l'art et de la calédonie de mayotte
et de la france dont elles font partie
et j'espère pour l'instant qu'elle y
resterons aussi longtemps que possible
comme le disait d'ailleurs jean marie
tjibaou la puissance de l'esprit est
éternel et je crois c'est ce qui va nous
quitter
cet après midi merci merci monsieur le
rapporteur dans la suite de notre
discussion générale
la parole est maintenant aux hommes
madame anne marie escoffier groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
la parole d'un sénateur monsieur le
président madame la ministre monsieur
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur le texte que nous
discutons aujourd'hui ne sera sans doute
pas dans cette session extraordinaire du
parlement
celui qui retiendra le plus l'attention
de l'opinion publique mais il n'en
demeure pas moins essentiel dans la
mesure où sa porte et concernent
directement deux territoires de la
nation même s'ils comptent
géographiquement parlant parmi les plus
éloignées puisque relevant de ce qu'il
est convenu de nommer les territoires
ultramarins
je veux parler de l'île de mayotte est
de l'archipel de la nouvelle calédonie
et île de mayotte dans cet archipel des
comores dont un récent est tragique
accident d'avion ayant frappé des
français des mahorais nous a brutalement
rappelé les liens l'unissant à la france
est une terre d'anciennes relations
elle est entrée dans l' empire colonial
sous louis philippe en 1846 avant d'être
rattachée à madagascar en 1909 et de
devenir un territoire d'outre-mer en
1946 à l'autonomie accrue par les lois
de 1956 1961 et 1968
or malgré l'accession des comores à
l'indépendance en 1975 mayotte
collectivité départementale régie par la
loi du 13 juillet 2001 a toujours
manifesté sa volonté de demeurer
française le projet de loi qui nous est
soumis se borne à constater les
résultats du référendum du 29 mars
dernier
approuvée par 94 % de la population et
qui ouvre la voie de la
départementalisation de l'île
celle ci constituant en puissance si on
ne peut que s'en réjouir
le 101e département de la république
je ne puis donc que souhaiter que cette
départementalisation s'opère d'une
manière harmonieuse et paisible dans
l'intérêt de mayotte comme dans celui de
la france je relève cependant que
l'alignement sur le droit commun des dom
sera long le droit applicable à mayotte
étant largement d'ego dérogatoire
l'absence d'impôts d'état de tva et de
fiscalité communale
l'application d'un droit statutaire
effet et familiale coutumier musulmans
la compétence d'une justice exercée par
le caddy en matière notariale était
assis ville l'existence d'un double
système d'état civil ou la
reconnaissance de la propriété foncière
coutumières sont autant de difficultés
qu'il faudra prendre en considération
les efforts seront importants et il
appartiendra à l'état de veiller à ce
que cet alignement ne laisse pas son
développement ni économique ni sociale
de même il appartiendra à l'état de
mettre en place des outils préventifs
permettant de placer le futur
département d'outre-mer dans une
situation financière satisfaisante tant
au regard des dépenses à venir qui lui
seront imputés et de ses dotations que
de la nouvelle autonomie de décision qui
lui échoir à la situation de la nouvelle
collègue du nid et plus comme en plus
complexes et avant de commenter la
partie du texte la concernant je
voudrais en prologue soulignait combien
l'accord dit de nouméa du 5 mai 1998
suivi de la loi organique du 19 mars
99 ont constitué non seulement une
avancée significative entre les
relations france nouvelle calédonie mais
encore ont illustré une manière de
gouverner particulièrement sage prudente
et efficace trop rarement mises en
oeuvre dans notre histoire
ce fut en effet à l'initiative de michel
rocard premier ministre que nous devons
l'extinction de cet incendie que des
mesures maladroite avait allumé ce
qu'ils finançaient entourant
d'interlocuteurs particulièrement
expérimentée qui ne privilégiaient hier
qu'une seule chose comme aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs le dialogue et le respect
absolu de ceux qui ne partageaient pas
la même opinion mais qui se trouve est
appelée à siéger à la même
nous aimerions que aujourd'hui le
gouvernement s'inspire à cette méthode
initiée jadis par le grand félix éboué
en afrique qui est certes la plus
difficile mais la plus efficace et reste
à bien des égards en modèle cette
éthique de la tolérance
elles étaient pratiquées encore avec un
rare bonheur par un sénateur du groupe
auquel gérable l'honneur d'appartenir
gaston monnerville longtemps président
de notre institution qui fut
après-guerre l'inde et efficace
promoteur de la transformation des trois
colonies caribéenne en département la
guyane la guadeloupe et la martinique
cette même année 1946 où la nouvelle
calédonie passade l'état de colonies à
celui de territoires d'outre-mer et vite
enfin aboli le détestable code de
l'indigénat
mais avant de parvenir aux accords de
matignon combien de pages violente
s'était écrite dans cet archipel
calédonien découvert le 4 septembre 1774
par l'expédition de cook et dont la
france prit pris officiellement
possession moins d'un siècle plus tard
le 24 septembre 1853 non pas dans
l'intention d'aménager cette nouvelle
terre mais dans celle d'en faire un
bagne un bagne qui fut non seulement
celui du second empire mais encore celui
de la troisième république qui l'envoya
quelques-uns des plus emblématiques
condamné de la commune en particulier
une femme madame la ministre qui par la
force de ses convictions et de son
caractère a ouvert à nous autres les
femmes le périlleux chemin de l'entrée
dans la voie politique je veux parler
naturellement ici de louise michel
bien entendu il n'est pas dans mes
intentions de rappeler ici la longue et
complexe histoire de la nouvelle
calédonie mais je voudrais tout de même
souligner que parmi les histoires de
tous ces territoires qu'on appelle
parfois les confettis de l'empiré celle
de la nouvelle calédonie fut
probablement l'une des plus violentes de
la tête du chef hatay
en effet conservé depuis 1878 dans un
bocal à paris au musée de l'homme
jusqu'aux émeutes des années 80 88 avec
la tragique affaire de la grotte d'ouvéa
ou l'assassinât du leader
indépendantiste jean-marie tjibaou
les relations entre paris et l'archipel
calédonien ne furent en effet ni simple
ni sereine tout cela était sans doute la
conséquence d'un schéma évolutif
complexe mêlant indistinctement le bagne
le nickel la pêche à la baleine le
développement des grandes propriétés au
seul profit de quelques-uns et non l'art
et la non reconnaissance par une
république éradicatrice aigles auto fage
de la spécificité de la culture kanak
c'est dire une fois de plus combien
après la loi defferre de 1956 la loi
stian de 1974 et la loi du 4 mai 1984
l'accord de matignon de 89 fut
exemplaire
un peu moins d'une décennie plus tard
l'accord dit de nouméa qui suivit en 98
avec la loi organique du 19 mars
99 prévoyait la mise en place
progressive d'une autonomie forte avec
des transferts de compétences successifs
or les missions régaliennes de l'état et
participaient à la construction d'un
destin commun et à la mise en place
d'une citoyenneté calédonienne et c'est
précisément à la suite de l'application
de ce dernier accord qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui une nouvelle décennie plus
tard au terme de quatre années de
travaux préparatoires sous l'autorité du
haut commissaire en nouvelle calédonie
en concertation avec les autorités de
l'archipel dont les conclusions ont été
approuvés une fille née au mois de
décembre dernier par le comité des
signataires de l'accord de nouméa
la nouvelle calédonie de ce fait est une
collectivité d'outre-mer régie par les
articles 76 et 77 de la constitution
dont le statut est précisément fixée par
cette loi de 90,9 qui l'a dotée des
institutions suivantes un congrès
la proportionnelle assemblées
délibérantes un gouvernement élu par le
congrès est responsable devant lui
organe exécutif dirigé par un président
un sénat coutumier désignés par les
conseils coutumier des conseils
coutumiers locaux et un conseil
économique et social un mot pour
souligner l'intérêt qu'offre la
reconnaissance du droit coutumier qui
concerne particulièrement l'état des
personnes et le droit de la famille
un droit coutumier qui effectivement
fils n'est pas conforme
allez à l'idée du droit positif que se
faisait etienne portalis dont le regard
nous accompagnent dans cet hémicycle
n'en est pas moins un sage garant de la
paix sociale et culturelle et montrent
qu'une république serait née celle qui
sait empiriquement s'adapter aux
situations et non imposer un modèle non
conformes à des sensibilités différentes
de celles de la métropole
ce projet de loi organique à d'abord
pour but de faciliter les transferts de
compétences prévus par l'accord de
nouméa et d'actualiser l'organisation
institutionnelle de l'île à travers
trois axes principaux le premier met en
action une organisation plus progressive
des transferts pour permettre au congrès
de mettre en oeuvre des préalables
le deuxième renfort ces garanties pour
le droit à compensation et la mise à
disposition des services par la
modification des règles de calcul et la
complète réorganisation des transferts
de services
le troisième instaure une
complémentarité entre les services de
l'état et ceux de la nouvelle calédonie
ce texte a également mission de
moderniser les institutions de nouvelle
calédonie en ouvrant de nouvelles
possibilités d'intervention dans la vie
économique locale aux collectivités
publiques de la nouvelle calédonie en
s'inspirant on ne peut que s'en réjouir
des dispositions déjà applicable en
polynésie française en france enfin au
niveau institutionnel ce texte
actualise opportunément le droit
applicable aux élus en matière de
remplacement d'indemnités
de protection d'incompatibilité et
d'inéligibilité
ces nouveaux transferts marcu n'est pas
une étape importante dans la perspective
du référendum d'autodétermination qui
sera organisé entre 2014 et 2018 et vise
à lui permettre d'effectuer une sorte
d'apprentissage de ces nouveaux outils
dans la perspective éventuelle d'une
future indépendance
l'ensemble des compensations financières
sera en revanche indexé sur la dgf qui
on le sait va connaître dans les
prochaines années
un tassement important en raison de la
modification du calcul de l' enveloppe
normée qui n'intègre plus que la seule
inflation et ce ne sera pas le seul
problème que devra affronter l'archipel
qui d'une part ne reçoit aucune
compensation particulière mais encore
aura bien du mal avec le transfert des
personnels tos techniciens ouvriers de
service
en revanche constituent des points
positifs la possibilité donnée à la
collectivité de nouvelle calédonie et
aux provinces de prendre des
participations en capital dans des
sociétés privées chargées d'une mission
de service public ou d'intérêt général
de créer des jets ip ou des scènes
locales tout en soumettant ces personnes
publiques à la plupart des dispositions
de la loi sapin la réforme des
collectivités locales
enfin l'intérêt sera particulièrement
puisque l'intercommunalité constituera
un autre outil de poids pour aider les
communes les plus pauvres en leur
permettant de mutualiser leurs moyens
écrit dans une logique qui depuis deux
décennies s'inscrit clairement dans le
domaine du consensus ce texte ne peut
que recueillir l'approbation des élus
des deux bords de notre haute assemblée
traditionnellement ouverte aux intérêts
des collectivités locales et
territoriales ainsi qu'aux libertés dont
doivent pouvoir jouir sans réserve nos
compatriotes à quelques territoires
qu'ils appartiennent dans le respect de
leurs spécificités
pour autant ce projet de loi n'était
sans doute pas parfait à l'origine ce
qui a conduit la commission des lois
sont excellents
rapporteur à revoir la rédaction et le
nom de certains ses actifs par
l'adoption de plus de quarante cinq
amendements dont je suis sûre le
gouvernement saura mesurer l'intérêt
c'est pourquoi sous réserve de
l'acceptation de ces amendements le
groupe rds votre à un texte qui
s'inscrit dans la tradition humaniste
qu'il a toujours défendues et s'adapte
au plus près aux besoins de nos
compatriotes calédonien lointains par la
distance mais proche par le coeur merci
madame le sénateur la part est
maintenant monsieur bernard frimat
pour le groupe socialiste
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues
l'histoire a retenu que ce sont deux
gouvernements dirigés en 1988 par michel
rocard en 1990 par lionel jospin en
liaison étroite avec tous les acteurs
locaux qui ont fait évoluer positivement
le dossier calédonien leur démarche
commune était fondé sur une stratégie d'
écoute et de dialogue tout le monde a
encore en mémoire la sau en mai 88 de la
grotte d'ouvéa par l'armée la
gendarmerie puis la mission dit du
dialogue
dirigée par le préfet christian blanc il
n'y a pas eu de miracle soudain mais une
longue et lente approche des personnes
et de leurs problèmes et peu à peu une
conviction que quelque chose était
possible qu'ils pouvaient conduire à une
sorte de décrispation enchaîne des
mentalités et des réactions pouvant
mener à la paix le 26 juin 1988 les
partenaires calédonien signent les
accords de matignon oudinot avec une
poignée de main historique entre michel
rocard qui était accompagné par notre
ancien collègue louis le pensec ministre
des dom-tom
jacques lafleur et jean marie tjibaou le
processus de matignon résiste à
l'assassinât de jean marie tjibaou et de
iéna irene survenu à ouvéa le 4 mai 1989
le scrutin d'autodétermination de 1990
désigné comme un référendum couperet
aurait pu mettre un terme à cette
évolution pacifique
il n'en a pas été ainsi car les
appréhensions des partenaires
attiser l approche de cette échéance ont
été surmontées sous l'action conjuguée
du premier ministre lionel jospin de
jean-jack queyranne sans secrétaire
d'état à l'outre-mer ni le fn ni ps ni
le rpr n'ont voulu prendre la
responsabilité de la division de la
nouvelle calédonie et des affrontements
la signature de l'accord de nouméa le 5
mai traduit juridiquement par la loi du
19 mars à doter la nouvelle calédonie
d'une organisation inédite adapté à son
identité propre
faisant une large part à l'identité
kanak établissement une citoyenneté
calédonienne au sein de la nationalité
française et prenant en compte la
nécessité du rééquilibrage économique et
sociale du territoire notamment par
l'application de la notion d'emploi
local il ne s'agit pas ici de détailler
le fil des événements la tâche revient
aux chercheurs aux historiens aux
acteurs de cette histoire qui continue
de s'écrire
chaque jour nous faisons simplement le
constat que personne ne peut nier qu'on
peut simplement oublié de mentionner
qu'il a été donné à la gauche de
conduire l'évolution de la nouvelle
calédonie dans la voie de la
réconciliation
l'évocation du passé permet d'illustrer
une méthode gouvernementale qui a fait
ses preuves et qui n'a heureusement
jamais été remise en cause par les plus
hautes autorités actuelles de l'état
les déclarations du président de la
république du premier ministre et de
votre prédécesseur au scrabble aux
secrétaires d'état à l'outre-mer sont
sans équivoque
permettez moi une fois n'est pas coutume
alors pourquoi mon privilège
de citer les propos de françois fillon
devant le comité des signataires
il déclaré l'accord de nouméa res la
feuille de route commune et constitue
pour l'état un engagement
la campagne électorale qui a précédé les
élections provinciales de 2009 a montré
que la situation calédonienne rester et
reposer sur un équilibre qui restait
fragile le climat politique s'est tendue
à droite comme à gauche néanmoins chacun
assumer ses responsabilités dans le
cadre d'institutions qui ont fait preuve
une nouvelle fois de leur stabilité
parce que la logique de la collégialité
et l'esprit de construction commune ont
prévalu
l'état pour sa part doit tenir ses
engagements il doit assumer son rôle en
veillant à l'application loyal de
l'accord de nouméa notamment en matière
de transferts de compétences mais aussi
en agissant pour le rééquilibrage
économique en nouvelle calédonie c'est
parce qu'elle s'inscrit dans cette
perspective
et qu'elle respecte l'esprit et la
lettre de l'accord de nouméa que le
groupe socialiste approuve les
propositions du rapporteur est prêt à
adopter les textes proposés par la
commission des lois
si ceci nous donne satisfaction sur le
fond la forme dans laquelle le sénat a
été appelé en délibéré n'en est pas
moins inacceptable
même si je vous donne acte madame la
ministre que ce n'est absolument pas de
votre responsabilité
les conditions d'examen du projet de loi
organique et du projet de loi parle
d'elle-même adopté en conseil des
ministres le 17 juin
ces projets sont déposés le jour même
sur le bureau du sénat et transmis à la
commission des lois le rapport de
christian cointat est adopté le 24 juin
sept jours après et je salue je dirais à
travers lui l'administration de la
commission des lois pour le remarquable
travail qui a été effectué et je salue
lui d'avoir réussi à produire un rapport
dont tout le monde reconnaît la qualité
mais ce n'est pas parce que le rapport
des qualités que l'administration a bien
fait son travail que nous devons
travailler dans les conditions qui sont
insupportables d'autant plus que tout
doit être terminé
au cours de cette session extraordinaire
nous sommes bien loin monsieur le
président de la revalorisation des
travaux parlementaires dont on nous
rabat les oreilles lors de la révision
constitutionnelle
cette révision était censé assurer à la
première assemblée saisis nous en
l'occurrence un délai incompressible de
six semaines entre eux le dépôt du
projet de loi et son examen en séance
publique le rétrécissement la dépasse je
dirais en matière de lessivage tout ce
qu'on peut imaginer de six semaines
nous sommes réduits à une à trois
semaines et à une semaine au niveau de
la commission
bien sûr sauf procédure accélérée la
procédure accélérée mes chers collègues
est devenue la règle ordinaire
d'organisation des débats et nous avait
été pourtant présenté comme un recours
exceptionnel appelé à limiter les abus
de l'ancien procédure d'urgence
or deux sets la procédure accélérée
supprime la navette parlementaire
la commission mixte paritaire devient le
lieu d'élaboration du texte définitif
sans débat public alors qu'elle devrait
selon la constitution se limiter à être
une instance de compromis pour les
quelques points encore en désaccord
à l'issue d'une navette normal quels que
soient les arguments avancés pour
justifier une telle situation le fait
que le sénat n'est disposé que d'une
semaine pour examiner les 42 articles du
projet de loi organique
les dix articles du projet de loi simple
n'est pas admissible
le rapporteur a parlé en cultivant avec
un art que je salue la litote
je cite de délais d'examen excessivement
court alors qu'il a été contraint de
réaliser ces auditions et d'élaborer ces
propositions quelques jours or ces deux
projets de loi comporte des dispositions
complexes et déterminante pour l'avenir
tant de mayotte que de la nouvelle
calédonie dans ces conditions consacré
de temps nécessaire
un examen approfondi n'aurait pas été
superflu
les dispositions relatives à mayotte
vise à inscrire dans la loi le
changement de statut de cette
collectivité
il s'agit de respecter l'engagement du
gouvernement de présenter au parlement
un projet de loi organique au cours de
cet été afin de tirer les conséquences
de la consultation du 29 mars 2009
n'aurait-il pas été plus respectueux à
l'égard des élus mahorais et de la
population mahoraise de traiter en
propre dans le cadre d'un projet de loi
organique distincts même réduits à un
article la question de l'évolution
institutionnelle de cette collectivité
d'autant que la départementalisation
devrait impliquer la programmation sur
plusieurs années d'un effort financier
exceptionnel de l'état le rapport
d'information monsieur le président de
la commission des lois que vous aviez
fait avec christian cointat michel andré
yves detraigne sur la déportation
marriott est on ne peut plus clair c'est
le rapport d'information 115 jean
conseil de nouveau la lecture
de plus l'intitulé même du projet de loi
madame la ministre est une source
possible de confusion puisqu'il semble
lier l'évolution institutionnelle de
mayotte à celle de la nouvelle calédonie
il vous appartenait de dissiper toutes
les équivoques et de réaffirmer
solennellement qu'il n'y a aucun lien
institutionnel entre mayotte et la
nouvelle calédonie vous l'avez fait dans
votre propos introductif
nous en prenons acte mais sa ré quand
même était plus simple si vous n'aviez
pas eu à faire ce travail et si nous
étions trouvés en présence de deux
textes différents
je pense que tant la nouvelle calédonie
que mayotte le mériter pour la nouvelle
calédonie n'a pas été simple de définir
le périmètre et les modalités des
transferts de compétences ces projets de
loi sont le point d'aboutissement d'un
long processus d'élaboration
ils ont nécessité la mise en place d'un
comité de pilotage depuis 2006 d'une
mission d'appui installée en février
l'ensemble ayant été validée par la
réunion du comité des signataires de
décembre 2008 conformément aux relevés
de ces conclusions de cette réunion
l'état a promis d'accompagner le
nouvelle calédonie pour l'exercice des
compétences dans le calendrier de
transfert est modifié cet accompagnement
doit faire l'objet de deux protocoles
l'un pour les règles concernant de droit
civil l'état civil et le droit
commercial l'autre pour la sécurité
civile or nous n'avons pas connaissance
du contenu et de la portée de ces
documents financiers
cette absence d'information alter
inévitablement l' appréciation
d'ensemble que nous pouvons porter sur
la réforme au congrès de nouvelle
calédonie et des élus se sont référés à
la célérité l'examen de ces textes pour
exprimer des réserves d'ailleurs nous ne
pouvons que déplorer à l'instar des élus
calédoniens que la réunion de
concertation initialement prévue entre
la réunion du comité des signataires de
décembre et l'examen des projets de loi
n'ait pas eu lieu
une consultation
mais n'était planifiée en mars 2009
cette réunion préparatoire n'a pas été
maintenu prendre le temps pour l'examen
de ces projets nous aurait permis de
dresser le bilan des accords qui ont
ouvert une ère de stabilité
institutionnelle et de développement
économiques jamais connu jusque-là en
nouvelle calédonie bilan des accords qui
ont placé ce territoire dans une
dynamique d'avenir en prenant en
considération le poids de l'histoire et
en parvenant à substituer aux catégories
des communautés à nouveau concept
désignant la communauté de destin des
femmes et des hommes de nouvelle
calédonie à ce titre tous les acteurs du
dossier calédonien porte une
responsabilité vis-à-vis de la
population du territoire dans la
construction de l'avenir et du maintien
de la paix le parlement a pleinement
joué son rôle dans l'évolution
institutionnelle de nouvelle calédonie
car c'est sur cet héritage en devenir
deux mots qui semblent en apparence
opposés mais qui sont porteurs de sens
se regarde l'histoire du territoire
c'est sur cet héritage en devenir qu'il
conviendrait en dépit de toutes ces
insuffisances de forme et elles sont
nombreuses les projets de loi présentés
reçoivent un autre accord sur le fond
ils sont la traduction des propositions
approuvées par le dernier comité des
signataires
ils s'inscrivent dans le processus
engagé depuis plus de 20 ans et modifie
en conséquence la loi organique
la question de l'organisation
progressive des transfert des
compétences de l'état de nouvelle
calédonie mérite une attention
particulière et j'y reviendrai cependant
on ne saurait passer sous silence les
autres dispositions des projets de loi
qui actualise et clarifie les règles de
fonctionnement des institutions
calédoniennes qu'il s'agisse du congrès
ou des autres collectivités publiques
nouvelle calédonie certaines
dispositions viennent consolider la
stabilité institutionnelle
en garantissant la continuité des
exécutifs de la nouvelle calédonie et
des provinces de nouveaux outils
d'intervention économique sont mis en
place
il devrait favoriser le rééquilibrage
entre les provinces et procédures
budgétaires et les dispositions
relatives aux finances locales sont
rendus plus transparentes
le contrôle est confortée avec le
renforcement des pouvoirs de la chambre
territoriale des comptes ainsi qu avec
l'adaptation et l'extension des recours
administratifs le statut des élus
calédoniens membres du congrès et des
assemblées des provinces et conseillers
municipaux est actualisée améliorée
enfin les mesures relatives à l'état
civil qui encadre les modalités de
changement de statut des personnes
viendront accroître la sécu la sécurité
juridique de l'état civil en nouvelle
calédonie le rapporteur s'est attaché à
compléter voire à amplifier les mesures
inscrites dans ses projets de loi nous
nous en réjouissons
il convient de souligner qu'il se
montrait attentif aux commentaires émis
par l'ensemble des personnes
auditionnées ainsi qu aux observations
exprimée par le congrès et les travaux
de la commission mis en évidence la
difficulté d'examiner ces projets doit
sans disposer de la totalité des
informations permettant au sénat de se
prononcer en connaissance de cause comme
les élus calédoniens qui ont tous
dénoncé cette carence
les sénateurs n'ont pas été destinataire
des protocoles d'accompagnement du
transfert des compétences
plusieurs amendements relatifs au calcul
de la compensation financière des
charges liées au transfert des
compétences en matière d'enseignement se
sont vus opposer l'irrecevabilité de
l'article 40
notons notons sur ce point que le
rapport numéro 490 monsieur cointat
deviendra assurément mes chers collègues
un collector parlementaire donc
n'hésitez pas à dévaliser
je dirais
bureau de la distribution pourquoi car
ce rapport reproduit en annexe tu tous
les amendements adoptés par la
commission y compris ceux déclarés
irrecevables au titre de l'article 40 de
la constitution
le 24 juin or 25
le lendemain la décision du conseil
constitutionnel sur notre règlement dont
tout le monde a pu apprécier le
caractère humoristique de certaines
considérations déclaration la décision
du grand essonne a considéré que tout
amendement frappé de lire ce haïti
fiancière ne peut être publié distribué
mis en discussion le contrôle de hre
s'inviter devant être effectif et
systématique au moment du dépôt y
compris auprès de la commission saisie
au fond je m'interroge
parce que finalement plus l'article 40
montre son incapacité à protéger la
france d'un déficit de plus en plus
majestueux plus le conseil
constitutionnel on souhaite une
application rigoureuse limitant le
pouvoir des parlementaires et le rôle du
parlement curieux paradoxe
et quand tout cela
et quant à tout cela mes chers collègues
on ajoute la capacité imaginative de la
commission des finances du sénat
tel que nous l'a expliqué tout à l'heure
christian cointat je pense
qu'effectivement la lecture d'alfred
jarry
mais pour nous à ce moment là qu'une
consolation toutefois la commission se
rapporter n'est pas restée sourde aux
préoccupations exprimées par le congrès
et a modifié le projet de loi organique
afin de renforcer certaines garanties
financières
cela concerne et c'est pas négligeable
les modalités d'application du terme de
la mise à disposition gratuite des
personnels de l'enseignement
le choix de la période de référence pour
les déterminer
on la compare à la compensation des
charges d'investissement et enfin la
continuité du financement des projets
lancés par l'état avant transfert de la
compétence ce qui permettra d'assurer le
financement de la construction des
lycées deux monts d'or et de poèmes ou
les accords de matignon
prévoyez un partage des compétences
entre l'état les provinces et le
territoire de la nouvelle calédonie pour
toute la durée des accords en revanche
l'un des éléments essentiels pour ne pas
dire l'élément essentiel de l'equilibre
de l'accord de nouméa et le trou de
nouméa et le transfert progressif et
irréversible des compétences de l'état à
la nouvelle calédonie les modalités de
l'exécution très ces transferts sont
déclinés au point 3 de l'accord
transfert immédiat transfert
intermédiaires et transfert à l'issue du
scrutin d'autodétermination pour les
compétences régaliennes les matières à
transférer au cours d'une étape
intermédiaire correspondant mandat des
congrès institué en 2004 et 2009 sont
visés vous le rappeliez monsieur le
rapporteur au troisièmement de l'article
21 daloa organique
partick 26 précise que les compétences
transférées et l'échéancier des
transferts doivent être définies par une
loi de pays adoptée à la majorité des
trois cinquièmes du congrès au plus tard
le dernier jour du sixième manche du 6e
mois suivant le début de chaque mandat
l'exécution de ces transferts
intermédiaire ayant accusé un retard en
2004 la loi de pays relatives à ces
transferts ben donc intervenir
impérativement dans l'état actuel du
texte avant le 30 novembre 2009 pour des
raisons pratiques et opérationnelles
il est apparu dès les travaux
préparatoires que les compétences en
matière de droit civil de règles
concernant l'état civil de droit
commercial et de sécurité civile
nécessiter un délai supplémentaire
le dernier comité des signataires a
ainsi unanimement et vous le rappeliez
approuvé un glissement de ces matières
de l'article 21 à l'article 27 de la loi
organique afin de permettre au congrès
de ne pas être soumis à ce délai de six
mois
pourtant bien que ce scénario du
transfert des compétences été élaboré
dans le consensus
la solution retenue dont la traduction
est inscrit 11 est inscrite aux articles
1er 3 dans l'est du projet de loi
organique dans sa version initiale
comporte un risque de dénaturation de
l'accord de nouméa
le dispositif retenu risque la censure
du conseil constitutionnel parce qu'il
rendrait aléatoire l'obligation
constitutionnelle de transférer alors
que l'accord de nouméa prévoit
clairement qu'en 2014
seules les compétences régaliennes ne
rompt pas été transféré il est curieux
que deux comités de pilotage la mission
d'un fouillis composé d'experts de
magistrats de hauts fonctionnaires n'est
pas attirer l'attention sur les
conséquences président yves prévisible
de la solution retenue est validé par le
comité des signataires
la menace de la transgression de
l'accord de nouméa a été soulevée par de
nombreux élus calédoniens
le groupe socialiste a partagé cette
crainte et la relayer vigoureusement
il est heureux que le rapporteur est
partagé cette analyse et modifier la
rédaction des articles 1er et 3 du
projet de loi organique
la solution retenue est pragmatique
puisqu'il est prévu de retarder non pas
le transfert mais la décision de
transfert des quatre compétences parce
qu'elle exige et tout le monde le
reconnaît
un temps de préparation plus long
tout en assurant dans la rédaction
approuvée à l'unanimité par là
commission des lois l'effectivité des
transferts en novembre 2009 et 2011
en revanche et je me réjouis que vous
ayez adopté cette solution il ne semble
pas nécessaire de soldes et l'hypothèse
où le congrès ne leur ait pas de loi de
pays relative au transfert ni le cas où
il ne ferait que pour certaines
compétences
l'équation calédoniennes en matière de
transferts repose sur une mathématique
politique
imparable l'automaticité des transferts
doit conjuguer tous risques
d'immobilisme veillant à ne pas brûler
les étapes
la problématique de la sortie de
l'accord se pose dans les mêmes termes
qu'elle se posait hier pour les accords
de matignon il faut il travailler sans
chercher à instrumentaliser les règles
de gouvernance de la nouvelle calédonie
six en organique prévoit que les
transferts de compétences doivent être
décidées par le congrès à la majorité
des 3 5e
c'est pour les solenniser par une
manifestation périodique de quasi
consensus
ce n'est pas pour les remettre en cause
l'accord de nouméa a pris en compte la
poursuite du rééquilibrage économique et
sociale entre les trois provinces dont
l'élément déterminant et la réalisation
effective de lusine du nord la province
nord qui est partie prenante
la nouvelle calédonie a connu ces
dernières années une forêt économique
exceptionnelle sous le double effet des
investissements publics et de la flambée
des cours du nickel la stabilité
politique a facilité son intégration
régionale dans le pacifique avec un
revenu par habitant qui avoisine ceux de
l'astre ali ou de la nouvelle zélande la
nouvelle calédonie suscite de plus en
plus l'intérêt des états océaniens
mais aujourd'hui rattrapée par la crise
elles risquent de connaître une
explosion sociale
le creusement des inégalités constitue
un risque politique majeur
un quart et chers collègues des ménages
quel et devient vit sous le seuil de
pauvreté relative le salaire minimum
brut est égal à un peu moins de 70% de
son équivalent métropolitain et une
récente enquête de l'ufc que choisir a
révélé que le panier de la ménagère
étaient 96 % plus cher qu'en métropole
cette disparité créer une société a deux
vies
s ayons le courage de reconnaître
minorité urbaines aisées essentiellement
européenne population majoritairement
kanak peut former et défavorisées il
faut renforcer la notion d' équilibre
politique à l'origine de la
provincialisation justement instauré par
les accords de matignon
et comment leur a forcé en développant
par des projets structurants un
rééquilibrage spatial
celui ci doit s'accompagner de
politiques sociales volontariste pour
réduire les disparités importantes des
niveaux de vie qui marque qui marque
toujours la société calédonienne et
pourrait partir plus équitablement les
richesses locales
en conclusion un seul président au nom
du groupe socialiste
je forme le double veut que nous
puissions adopté ces deux projets de loi
à l'unanimité pour donner à notre
délibération toute la force nécessaire
et que l'assemblée nationale ait la
sagesse de ne pas remettre en cause le
point d'équilibré
ainsi trouvé ce serait à mes yeux la
meilleure manière
mes chers collègues madame la ministre
de confirmer les acquis du passé et
d'assurer en nouvelle calédonie les
voies d'un avenir pacifique
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
président la parole m attend notre
collègue adrien giraud pour le groupe de
l'union centriste avait la parole mon
cher collègue
je
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je tiens tout
d'abord à remercier monsieur le
président de la république et le
gouvernement d'avoir organisé une
consultation sur la question depuis si
longtemps posé par les mahorais enfin
deux dotés d'un statut définitif au sein
de la république française
c'est avec un score sans appel à 95%
viril de ma chère collègue madame
assassines que les mahorais se sont
prononcés le 29 mars dernier pour que
mayotte devienne en 2011 le 101e
département français d'outre-mer
ceci est le résultat de notre longue
marche patienter parfois douloureuses
vers un statut répondant aux espoirs de
plusieurs générations de maoré le projet
de loi organique proposé aujourd'hui
garantir à la constitutionnalité de
cette évolution statutaire mais il
s'agit pas seulement d'obtenir la
départementalisation
il s'agit surtout de la réaliser et la
réussite il faut tout d'abord éviter le
risque de plaquages institutionnels
notre territoire et désireux de se
développer rapidement pour répondre aux
besoins d'une population qui a subi de
nombreux retards mais aussi espoir d'une
jeunesse nombreuse et ardente
il faudra redire ici il est mort et ne
se ne souhaitait pas tomber dans les
facilités des sociétés de consommation
ou de l'assistanat généralisé mais
développer des activités productives
génératrice d'emplois et de richesses
c'est une volonté de développement
endogène dans le cadre de la solidarité
nationale et
opère ainsi l'organisation
départementale de mayotte devra
conjuguer efficacité et simplicité
nous voulons être un département
d'outre-mer qui ne suppose pas les
organes et les compétences relevant du
département et de la région
nous souhaitons une organisation
originale novatrice de la
départementalisation du trouvère dans un
premier temps il faudrait compléter
rapidement le cadre législatif et
réglementaire nécessaire à la
réalisation de nos projets enfin de
mettre en place un plan vigoureux de
développement économique et social qui
nous assure un véritable de rattrapage
mais sans oublier la protection des plus
démunis et notamment des personnes âgées
et de proue vue de toute ressource dans
son intervention à versailles lors du
congrès du 22 juin dernier le chef de
l'état a reconnu la place de l'outre-mer
et la nécessité d'un traitement
spécifique de nos problèmes il s'agira
donc d'adapter à notre situation
particulière
ce nouveau cadre institutionnel si l'on
veut éviter les dangers du nas milices
assimilation trop théorique oublieuse de
nos spécificités insulaires le droit
public français a multiplié depuis
longtemps les règles et les modalités
différencier de la loi républicaine
c'est le cas pour paris pour les
départements alsaciens pour la corse ou
bien entendu pour les départements
d'outre-mer mayotte attentes se
prévaloir de ses spécificités pour
réaliser l'application la plus efficace
du système juridique français
bien au delà du plan de relance élaboré
par le gouvernement
il sera nécessaire de programmer en
moyens et l'autre et long terme les
opérations de restructuration et de
modernisation de l'économie mahoraise à
cet égard les équipements nécessaires au
fonctionnement du deuxième quai du port
de longoni et l'allongement de la piste
aérienne sont les opérations
prioritaires pour son désenclavement et
le développement de ce genre il est
nécessaire d'en finir avec le cepd 1 les
sets
les sempiternels refrain des études
préalables et jamais terminé pour entrer
enfin dans le domaine de réalisation les
états généraux de l'outre-mer sont
ouverts la honte ouvert la voie ils
s'inscrivent dans la continuité de la
consultation sur la départementalisation
l'intérêt pour ces états généraux et
croissants à mayotte
la population veut maintenant participer
à l'élaboration du nouveau statut il est
devenu urgent de concrétiser toutes ces
bonnes intentions pour préparer la
transformation de mayotte en statue du
trot mer français à partir de 2011 en
émaux mayotte a besoin d'un véritable
plan sur son de son économie qui
regrouperait la relance des activités
agricoles et vivrière la modernisation
de la pêche un vigoureux programme de
formation de la jeunesse
il est donc essentiel de poursuivre
activement les efforts entrepris depuis
plusieurs années
en effet l'effectif croissant des
enfants scolarisés et l'augmentation du
niveau de nos étudiants sont à coup sûr
des indices les plus encourageants
l'éducation est le maire fondement du
progrès de mayotte
il est cependant regrettable que les
efforts réalisés par état au niveau de
l'éducation nationale soit partiellement
réduit par la présence massive d'enfants
clandestins que nous allons que nous
avons l'obligation de scolariser
il est essentiellement d'assurer une
juste application du contrat de projet
de mayotte 2008 2014 dans un esprit de
solidarité et dans une volonté de
responsabilité partagée qui sont les
meilleurs cage du de progrès madame la
ministre je souhaiterais qu une
régularisation interviennent au bénéfice
de tous les fonctionnaires de l'état et
du nouveau département de mayotte
en effet selon l'article 2 de la loi 50
très 772 du 30 juin 1950 les personnels
civils et militaires en service dans les
territoires relevant du ministère de
l'outre-mer doivent recevoir une
indexation de leur salaire cette
indexation à cesser de s'appliquer à
mayotte en vertu de l'article 9 du
décret 78 très 119 du 12 décembre mais
le censeur 1978 or tous les agents
publics des autres territoires et
départements d'outre-mer continue
pourtant de bénéficier d'une indexation
de leur salaire les fonctionnaires de
maeyer réclament dans leur établissement
légitime de l'indexation des salaires
il s'agit bien sûr de réparer cette
discrimination madame la ministre suisse
mais c'est surtout de compenser la
cherté de vide à mayotte
je prendrai à ce propos un exemple fin
décembre 2008
l' indice des prix de la zone franche
entière métropole plus dom n'a augmenté
que de 1% en glissement annuel contre
5,1 à mayotte
j'ai déjà posé cette question au
gouvernement en 2008 et à votre
prédécesseur mais je n'ai reçu aucune
réponse satisfaisante
il est également anormal aujourd'hui de
constater qu'au moment de l'intégration
des fonctionnaires de mayotte dans la
fonction publique
l'administration ne veut pas tenir
compte de leur ancienneté
alors qu'il souffre lui ont servi l'état
est là
activité durant ce 30 à 50 ans le statut
actuel de mayotte vis-à-vis de l'union
européenne et celui des p t om pays et
territoires d'outre-mer pays les moins
avancés et dans ce cadre elle bénéficie
du fed fonds européen de développement
l'un des enjeux de d'attention nations
en 2011 de notre collectivité en
département et de la faire accéder au
statut de région ultrapériphérique rup
et par conséquent lui donner la
possibilité de bénéficier des fonds
structurels européens
en effet le traité actuel instituant la
communauté européenne qui mentionne les
départements d'outre-mer doit permettre
à mayotte de devenir une région
ultrapériphérique l'europe pourrait
ainsi contribuer davantage à son
développement
aussi dans le cadre du traité actuel
c'est la suppose une ferme volonté
politique du gouvernement ainsi qu'un
engagement un soutien auprès des
institutions communautaires
nous y sommes prêts à toutes les
adaptations requises le conseil statuant
à la majorité qualifiée que arrêter des
mesures spécifiques pour fixer les
conditions d'application du traité en
tenant compte des caractéristiques et
contraintes particulières des régions
ultrapériphériques soon sans nuire à
l'intégrité et à la cohérence de l'ordre
juridique communautaire
je demande au gouvernement que lors de
la prochaine programmation des fonds
structurels notre département puces à
naître bénéficiaires mais sur pays norme
dans la ministre mes chers collègues à
cette crédules je tiens à redire ma
profonde gratitude et celle de la
population de mayotte que je représente
au président nicolas sarkozy
merci
je vous remercie circuler la parole est
à mme aïda méliane à ceux ci
g
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mais chers collègues les sénatrices et
sénateurs du groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen ont toujours
soutenu l'évolution institutionnelle de
la nouvelle calédonie ce territoire
peuplé depuis 4000 ans par des tribus
d'origine mélanésienne mélanésienne
pardon a été annexé par la france en
1853 le peuple kanak
ainsi a été dépossédée de ses terres le
travail obligatoire lui a été imposée
comme des tact et autres mesures nuancé
droit à partir de 1946 année où la
nouvelle calédonie devient un territoire
d'outre-mer les contours d'une certaine
autonomie se dessine mais une autonomie
dont le contenu varie en fonction des
gouvernements en place en métropole les
révoltes de la population kanak sont
ainsi fréquent dans un climat de
violences opposant les deux communautés
principal kanak et européennes
jusqu aux terribles événements de 1988
survenues sur l'île d'ouvéa et durant
lesquelles
vingt-et-une personnes trouvèrent la
mort les tensions politiques
s'apaiseront après la signature des
accords de matignon le 26 juin 1988 qui
rétabliront la paix et la stabilité
institutionnelle
si le référendum sur l'auto
détermination qu'il prévoyait n'a pas eu
lieu 10 ans après des négociations sur
l'avenir institutionnel du territoire
sont engagés et aboutissent le 5 mai 98
à la signature de l'accord de nouméa
cet accord dont le préambule évoque je
cite les ombres de la période coloniale
et déterminant puisqu'il reconnaît
l'identité du peuple kanak et engage la
nouvelle calédonie vers la pleine
souveraineté
le 8 novembre 1998 ce sont près de 60
pour cent des néo calédonien qui
approuvent l'accord de nouméa
c'est un long processus qui s'est donc
mis en place en 1998 que la france se
devait d'accompagner démocratiquement en
1998 nous avons donc tout naturellement
approuvé la révision constitutionnelle
nécessaire pour la mise en oeuvre de
l'accord de nouméa du 5 mai 98 elle
constituait une étape capitale dans
l'histoire de la nouvelle-calédonie au
même titre que la loi organique
19 mars 99 à laquelle nous avons
également apporté notre soutien
inscrit dans un processus de
décolonisation et d'accès à la pleine
souveraineté de la nouvelle calédonie
l'accord de nouméa prévoit un partage
progressif des compétences entre l'état
et la nouvelle calédonie des compétences
seront transférées dès la mise en oeuvre
de la nouvelle organisation d'autres le
seront selon un calendrier défini modula
par le congrès selon le principe d'auto
organisation
vous venez de suivre une partie de
l'examen du projet de loi relatif à
l'évolution institutionnelle de mayotte
et de la nouvelle calédonie pour revoir
cette séance notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous avec les travaux
parlementaires demain 10h30 avec
l'audition de patrick devedjian par la
commission des finances du sénat
à suivre le 18 heures présenté par sonia
mabrouk et michel grossiord merci de
votre fidélité à très bientôt sur public
sénat